Don Lemon who was a well he purports to
be a journalist but then also says he's
not political you know he's not
political but he's also not a journalist
I mean he's just a guy who gives his
opinion poorly guys as a journalist he
got booted from the late night slot at
CNN and when you get booted on CNN they
don't fire you out right they either put
you on MSM they throw you another
Network like MSNBC or they give you the
morning slots so they threw him to the
morning anyway he was on Stephen
Colbert's late night show and Stephen
Colbert who you know the the budget on
that show is bananas he's got like 20
writers massive staff it used to be the
number one show in late night when
Letterman had it uh now it is not that's
Greg Gutfeld in his band of like three
people that he's got uh anyway lemon was
on Colbert and listened to what he says
about CNN and try not to fall out of
your seat and if you're drinking
something watch out for the spit take
the word on the street is that you guys
aren't allowed to be liberal anymore is
that is that the case I don't think you
ever were liberal what yes I don't think
everywhere that's not me saying that
that's the people out there saying that
he's not letting you be liberal anymore
well I listen I think that I think what
Chris is
saying is that he wants Republicans
sensible Republicans he wants us to hold
people to account but he wants people to
come on and feel comfortable with coming
on and talking on on CNN and appearing
on CNN so if you invite someone in your
house you want to make them comfortable
but also but by the nature of what we do
we have to hold people to account and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going liberal or conservative or
whatever it just means that we are doing
what we do and that's good journalism
he's such a shell of nothing with thick
room glasses like it's just nothing what
he's saying there he's showing you
exactly what the factory settings of all
of this stuff is the factory settings is
basically we are Democrats so when he's
framing that conversation he's saying
well you know uh it's not that we
weren't liberal what does he say uh in
essence at the same time we have to show
Republicans that we're nice well if you
weren't liberal then Republicans
wouldn't feel that way notice the
conversation never goes in the back he
doesn't go well we weren't conservative
so uh you know we have to be respectful
of Democrats like the the basic default
position that these people have is wrong
so then every conclusion that comes
after that is always wrong and of course
Colbert just getting up there and he's
just he's just nothing he's he's
absolutely nothing except what the
machine wants that's exactly what
Colbert which is precisely what I told
Bill Barr a couple weeks ago he was
Colbert
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody but the good part of that
is we don't hide it like he doesn't like
me and I don't like him and we don't
deny it and we don't like it no but he's
nothing yeah he's nothing very
successful no no but he's just giving
the machine what it wants all the time
you giving you for my differences with
you I totally respect you as well said
yeah giving the machine What It Wants I
wish I had thought of that phraseology
that so giving the machine what it wants
which is also what lemon is doing it's
what the people at MSNBC are doing it's
what it's what big Tech has done just
can we constantly keep everyone enraged
confused thinking Republicans are racist
can we lie about all of the issues
whether it is Coveted or very fine
people on both sides or the Jesse small
out hooks I do this all the time or
Brett Kavanaugh or Kyle Rittenhouse all
of the lies that they push because it oh
you know the police are racist and
systemic racism and boys or girl all of
the stuff guys you get it and and if you
keep giving the machine What It Wants
You Will you will get jobs I guess you
will be successful in media and
everything else it's a little harder I
suppose to to be honest and fight for
truth and reason and human rights I
suppose it's a little harder to do those
things but I think it's well worth it